-Now, I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
Spring Break haiku poems
from you guys.
This first one's from
@mic-- Micalean?
He says,
"Night has cooled the air.
Fire glows red as solo cups.
Trish pukes on the beach."
[ Laughter ]
That's beautiful.
-Wow.
Wow. I think I read that on
a Celestial Seasonings box.
-Oh, yes.
You're right.
-This is from @theladyabba.
She says,
"I don't need sunscreen.
Curse my human arrogance.
Pass the aloe, please."
[ Laughter ]
You've got to try it once.
-You've got to -- you know.
Come on.
-This one's from @NardJerry.
-NardJerry.
He says,
"Planned epic road trip.
Car broke down on the first day.
Spring break'd in Pittsburgh."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Ain't no party
like a party in Pittsburgh.
The party in Pittsburgh
don't stop.
This one's from
@cupcakesfordoughnuts.
-Ooh.
-Interesting conundrum.
She says,
"Dreamt of beaches, waves.
Wait, it rains in Miami?
Didn't know that. Crap."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it rains.
[ Applause ]
This one's from
@tylerhughes.
He says,
"Nine days off school. Wait.
Who's feeding the class gerbil?
Rest in peace, Sprinkles."
[ Laughter ]
-That was from the heart.
-Oops.
Yeah, that was...
Sprinkles.
That's a great name.
This one's from
@tweetonceforyes.
He says, "Lost -- wallet,
future career in public office.
Found -- good memories."
There you go.
He made a choice.
-Yeah.
-The last one's from
@rajanvlad1.
He says,
"The airport line is long.
Why are all these people here?
Oh, crap, it's Spring Break."
Yeah, there you go.
Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
And to check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtag.